When I was at Harvard Business School
back in 1990,
there were probably eight people in the
nonprofit club.
Um,
and I think we looked at slightly
askance by the folks because it wasn't
the venture capital club with the
finance club.
Now today on campus,
the largest single club at Harvard
Business School is the social enterprise
club.
So in 20 years or less than that,
you have had a shift in something pretty
fundamental in this country around I
think young people wanting to take more
responsibility for those around them,
seeing their responsibility slightly
more broadly defined than just motivated
self interest in getting involved.
So we have so many more young folks in
our colleges and our Grad schools today
mentoring our students,
volunteering,
getting involved in service movements
like Americorps and Vista.
So I,
I think the pendulum is certainly
swinging to a direction where many young
people are taking more responsibility
for those around them and realizing
that's not at odds with,
you know,
good old motivated self interest in free
market capitalism.
And in fact,
you know,
we all remember that and Smith wrote a
book called the wealth of nations.
And talked about free markets and
capitalism,
why they were good ultimately for our
society.
He also wrote another book.
It was talking about the theory of moral
essentials in what he said is you can
have a free market in,
it's going to work best,
but at the same time,
at some point you have to realize that
just getting more and more and more is
actually not in society's best interest.
So even Adam Smith as our free market
economy,
free market economies would say there's
a concept of being responsible for
others in wrote a book about that.
Equally,
I think we are.
Don't remember he actually wrote a few
books.
One of them talked about moral
essentials in the danger of just seeing
in a creative process without any sense
of what's enough or any sense of
distribution that I have the opportunity
now to help others.
Uh,
you know,
that's equally part of keeping a very
strong,
uh,
in,
in well functioning capitalist society
in check.
Certainly many,
many more Grad schools are offering loan
forgiveness or loan reduction for those
going into the nonprofit sector.
Um,
and I do think with the rise of social
entrepreneurship,
the rise of nonprofits hiring better and
better people growing more quickly,
that we're attracting incredible talent
into the sector.
And the reality is is people are getting
paid more and more.
So the gap between the nonprofit and
private sector is shrinking.
And certainly the last 10 years it's
shrinking from when I started back in
2000.
Um,
the other way I think about the is I'm
not a huge proponent of,
of handouts,
so I have not seen with people who are
able bodied enable minded,
they were handouts are producing good
outcomes in a sense of entitlement is a
very destructive sentiment.
And if you ever want to play the victim,
you're not going to get a hit.
So when I think about that pendulum,
it's,
there's a lot of personal accountability
that has to be invested in any nonprofit
organization.
I think that is serving someone who is
able bodied enabled minded.
I mean,
there,
there are needs for charitable acts or
needs for handouts for someone who
really cannot provide for themselves or
we slipped to a place where they
literally cannot take care of
themselves,
but that's not a majority.
I think,
of what we're trying to do here,
especially at Europe.
We believe you've got to combine deep
personal accountability,
taking charge of yourself.
Not saying woe is me,
but saying I want a chance.
I want an opportunity.
I mean,
America needs to be an opportunity
society.
And so the young adults we serve want an
opportunity.
They do not want a handout.
They want a hand up.
And so my belief is that pendulum in
terms of maybe reaching out and
supporting others also has to be
balanced by a healthy dose of personal
accountability for those being helped in
without.
Which I think,
uh,
I don't think the system will ever work
well.